kendall and kylie jenner are getting
drunk
one more shot i think we should start
the video with five shots
okay doing their makeup
i love your loot using blue shadows on
my lips
i love that having a lot of laughs i do
have to pee
and even a good old drunk cry when you
have your own daughter like you just
think about this
and i'm just like let's start at the
beginning kylie invites her older sister
kendall over to film a youtube video
the concept get drunk and get glam
beer purple girl
after kendall arrives the ladies get the
party started in the parking garage
sipping kendall's new tequila line eight
one eight
come on down the hatch
let's go oh hi
see with this i don't really need a
chaser okay
it's just the first one before they even
start applying makeup
the sisters are already five shots deep
that's when kendall shares a story that
makes kylie emotional
we'd be walking up the stairs and i'd
look at you and i'd be like can you see
my acne
i know clearly you could see my acne
bumps
on your face i know but like you would
every day you would say no you look
beautiful
she's fully crying tears down her face
it's just like when you have your own
daughter like you just think about this
it always like made me like so sad to
even hear you talk about it you know i'm
like you're so beautiful
i'm trying to help you but then i had to
go away by myself and be like oh
yeah it was so it makes me feel bad by
now
things are happening they're totally
slap happy putting on makeup
and even thinking about their next meal
i haven't had in and out in like a year
we should definitely go to mcdonald's is
right down the street i had it
mcdonald's two weeks ago
mama kris jenner facetimes and sees her
daughters are drunk
we're wasted oh my god i love you guys
giving us total amy poehler in mean
girls vibes
thank you next [ __ ] then things really
fly off the handle
kendall i think gosh
kind of a unique name
so is kylie we got more unique names
than our sisters
well it's true like what was mom kendall
and kylie
the makeup looks get progressively more
creative
i love that you're losing blue
and kendall gets straight up destructive
[Applause]
kylie yanks out one of kendall's hair
extensions clips it into her
own hair and they remind their fans to
drink responsibly
honestly the most fun i ever have when
i'm drunk
it's the most fun you'll ever have
when the sister duo isn't drinking and
having a blast together
they're busy with their own lives i like
to keep my private life pretty private
so um i try my best but at the same time
i don't i don't like to let
being seen out in public with someone
like affect my everyday life like if i
want to go grab
a smoothie with a friend who's a male
i'm not going to like
let the paparazzi like stop me from
doing that and living my life and just
being a normal person
a source told et earlier this month that
kendall's relationship with nba star
devin booker
is getting more serious i love it
as for kylie a separate source says she
and travis scott are still spending a
lot of time together
as they co-parent their daughter stormy
adding that they're still
loving feelings towards each other